France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'Europe cette semaine alors
que l'Ukraine annonce une grande
contre-offensive nous allons nous
pencher sur l'action de l'Union
européenne dans cette guerre autour de
Laurence Boone la secrétaire d'État à
l'Europe qui incarne le point de vue de
la France d'autres institutions vont
porter la contradiction la Commission
européenne avec le commissaire Schmitt
le Parlement avec des députés européens
comme Bernard Guetta pour la France et
le roumain Victor negrescu encore la
mairie de Paris pour les institutions
locales avec Anne Hidalgo regardons
leurs échanges en public au cœur de
Paris
l'Union européenne s'est bâtie sur un
projet de paix j'ai envie de dire si on
revient à ses origines Laurence Boone et
elle est rattrapée par la guerre oui
c'est un vrai bouleversement ça veut
dire quoi en fait c'est la première fois
depuis la naissance de l'Union
européenne que l'Union européenne
délivre des armes un pays tiers que
l'Union européenne s'engage avec des
missiles avec des chars avec des
ambitions pour aider un pays qui défend
l'intégrité de son territoire et puis
ces valeurs démocratiques que l'Union
européenne accueille autant de réfugiés
à qui elle donne immédiatement le droit
et la capacité de travailler pour qu'il
puisse vivre en temps de guerre et que
l'Union européenne fournit autant de
financement pour des choses aussi
simples aider les Ukrainiens à passer
l'hiver à payer les fonctionnaires à
faire fonctionner les écoles à maintenir
la lumière le chauffage pendant l'hiver
c'est
si une énorme première 50 milliards
d'euros en fait Monsieur le Commissaire
entre l'Union européenne et les États
membres de soutien à l'Ukraine la
Commission européenne qui a réagi par
une salve de sanctions contre les Russes
les États membres qui ont envoyé des
armes aussi aux Ukrainiens pour se
défendre vous diriez d'ailleurs vite et
bien oui tout cet argent c'est
effectivement pour pour que les
ukrainiens et les Ukrainiens puissent se
défendre
puisse défendre leur pays mais en même
temps puissent nous défendre puisque
c'est une guerre qui est menée a priori
contre les Ukrainiens en premier mais
c'est une guerre qui est menée contre
l'Europe mais aussi et surtout contre
nos valeurs et donc c'est de l'argent
qu'il faut investir pour aider les
Ukrainiens à défendre aussi nos valeurs
alors Bernard Guetta vous avez été
journaliste au Monde à France Inter bien
sûr mais avant cela correspondant à
Moscou est-ce que nous avons été nous
les Européens de l'Ouest un peu aveuglés
de nous croire en P perpétuel désormais
sur le sol européen dans le club des 27
est-ce que nous saurons arrêter la
guerre ce ne sont pas les Européens qui
ont été aveuglés par cette illusion
c'est tout le monde les Russes les
Américains les Européens
les Russes en premier n'ont absolument
pas cru même penser à la nécessité par
exemple d'organiser la stabilité du
nouveau continent européen celui qui
était sorti de l'écroulement de l'Union
soviétique et de la chute du mur de
Berlin donc il y a là une responsabilité
collective mais il ne faut jamais
oublier que les Russes ont été coupables
que les Américains ont été et que nous
l'avons été tous ensemble alors Victor
negrescu dans ce conflit on dit qu'il y
a deux Europe maintenant l'Europe de
l'Est qui pense que on a été très naïf à
l'ouest je pense que beaucoup de
dirigeants de l'ouest de l'Europe ont
été naïf parce que nous on parlait de
des problèmes que la Russie peut
représenter depuis longtemps déjà en
Roumanie il y a 3 millions de réfugiés
d'Ukraine qui ont passé à travers nos
pays et on a 200 000 qui ont décidé de
rester on est le premier pays à offrir
l'accès à l'éducation et à la santé au
réfugiés ukrainien à ce titre il faut
également se préparer pour l'avenir
d'une part il faut aider l'Ukraine on le
fait déjà de façon con sur les questions
qui sont liées à l'armée à la défense à
l'action qui se prépare maintenant en
Ukraine pour regagner du terrain mais il
faut également donner des réponses
claires sur les questions liées à la
constructions il faut également parler
par exemple de du transit décrées qui
vient du Rennes vers les pays d'Afrique
il y a beaucoup de questions très
complexes en fait le transition du blé
qui se passe mal en fait et pour les
pays limitrophes parce qu'il est stocké
sur place et 60% des reines qui viennent
du règne passe à travers la Roumanie et
il faut également penser à tous ces
détails là donc l'Europe a bien agi on
est fortuni on est uni et ça c'est très
bien mais il faut également réfléchir au
pas qu'on a préparé pour pour les années
à venir à ce titre j'invite également
tous les dirigeants européens à vraiment
parler de ça également détailler les
plans pour l'avenir alors justement à la
mairie de Paris Anne Hidalgo vous avez
mis à disposition un centre d'accueil
dans le 19e des réfugiés Ukrainiens des
aides financières aussi ciblées oui mais
au pas ça bien sûr accueillir tous les
déplacés réfugiés surtout des femmes des
enfants et des personnes âgées dans un
premier temps même si la France n'a pas
été le pays dans lequel il y a le plus
de réfugiés ou de déplacer
ukrainien et puis nommer les choses oui
c'est une guerre de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine c'est une guerre pour les
valeurs de l'Europe j'ai eu l'occasion
je l'ai dit d'aller trois fois en
Ukraine les soutenir y compris par des
actes et des gestes symboliques Paris
œuvre à l'échelle locale mais aussi à
l'échelle internationale puisque j'ai
pris la décision de porter la
candidature de Kiev au sein de
l'Association internationale des mers
francophones qui a été accepté ce qui
n'a pas été très simple parce que le
rapport par exemple d'un certain nombre
de pays africains ou de villes
africaines à l'égard de l'Ukraine
n'était pas simple accueillir les
réfugiés Ukrainiens comme nous l'avons
fait c'était parfait mais ça montrait
qu'on ne l'avait pas fait pour les
autres
et ça ça nous a été beaucoup reproché
c'est aussi une façon dans la diplomatie
des villes de faire comprendre à nos
amis des autres continents et notamment
du continent africain que puisque cette
guerre nous concerne ici en Europe en
fait elle les concerne aussi parce
qu'elle concerne tous les pays
démocratiques et y compris et je
j'insiste là dessus aussi parce que ça a
été un élément
très important dans la perspective de
l'accueil des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques bien sûr que la décision
d'accueillir ou pas les délégations
russes n'incompte pas à la mère de Paris
ça ne m'a pas échappé mais ça ne m'a pas
échappé que quand on est un responsable
politique on essaye aussi de porter une
parole porter le message de il s'agit
bien d'une agression de la Russie contre
l'Ukraine et on pourra pas regarder
ailleurs en 2024 lorsque les jeux se
dérouleront à Paris la présidente Ursula
vanderleon et a choisi de placer le 9
mai Journée de l'Europe très
symboliquement à Kiev aux côtés de
volody mirzelinski parce que la question
qui se pose maintenant pour l'Europe
c'est véritablement celle de l'adhésion
de l'Ukraine au club européen il faut
lui donner ses perspectives la crise ou
la guerre contre l'Ukraine menée par
Poutine à une histoire et il faut
remonter aussi
aux manifestations de la fameuse place
du Maidan
où les Ukrainiens ont exprimé
fortement leur volonté de faire partie
de l'Europe démocratique ils l'ont fait
à des drapeaux européens et c'était
finalement ça donnait chaud au cœur
puisque c'était les Ukrainiens un moment
ou parfois en Europe on discutait
beaucoup sur l'utilité de l'Europe que
les Ukrainiens ont exprimé cette volonté
d'appartenir à cette Europe de la
soutenir et de voir en Europe une chance
inouïe et donc la présence de la
présidence c'est à la fois rendre
hommage à ce combat des Ukrainiens mes
yeux c'est aussi souligner
que cette Ukraine appartient à l'Europe
on a fait référence au déplacés puisque
les Ukrainiens n'aiment pas le mot
réfugié au déplacé avec la mise en œuvre
d'une directive de protection temporaire
que les évidemment et j'ai pu constater
ce qui
la directive de protection temporaire
pour nos spectateurs en fait c'est vrai
que les Ukrainiens se sont vus attribués
un droit d'entrée dans l'Union
européenne de pouvoir travailler dans
l'Union européenne c'est une directive
de protection temporaire d'un an qui a
été effectivement renouvelé qui monte
d'ailleurs que c'est plutôt une bonne
approche quand il y a un problème de
réfugiés je rejoins tout à fait ce que
Madame la mère a dit sur le problème des
réfugiés en général mais en fait
l'Ukraine a maintenant un statut de
candidat à l'Union européenne ce qui
correspond à la fois au souhait des
Ukrainiens la volonté des Ukrainiens
mais c'est je crois aussi une
perspective forte pour nous pour l'Union
européenne d'accueillir ce pays
rappelons d'ailleurs Laurence bon au
passage que le pays s'est vu accorder le
statut de candidat une candidature
véritablement express à l'Union
européenne en 2022 mais pour une
majorité des talents peut-être même la
France
il est un peu tôt pour envisager une
adhésion très rapide quand même je sais
pas pourquoi vous dites ça parce qu'en
fait le pays sous lequel sous la
présidence duquel le statut de candidat
à l'adhésion a été donné à l'Ukraine
c'est sous la présidence française de
l'Union européenne qui a vrai énormément
pour l'Ukraine pour la Moldavie pour
donner une perspective européenne à la
Géorgie et pour rappeler l'importance de
tous les Balkans je suis probablement la
première secrétaire d'État chargée de
l'Europe qui commence à tourner
européenne par les Balkans par la modèle
vie par tous les pays vous savez qu'il y
en a 10 qui sont candidats à l'adhésion
donc je crois et c'est une des
constantes du président de la République
que l'Europe l'Union européenne et
maintenant avec la guerre la sécurité du
continent
passe par élargissement et on est
absolument très clair là-dessus c'est
une nouveauté quand même de dire que
finalement l'élargissement sert à ça à
sécuriser le continent mais en fait on
est dans une situation qui est quand
même ça fait 70 ans qu'on construit
l'Europe en disant qu'on construit la
paix et là on se prend la guerre à nos
frontières parce que monsieur le député
par tenait des frontières de la Roumanie
avec l'Ukraine la Finlande c'est 1300 km
de frontières avec la Russie il faut se
dire pour que ce soit très concret parce
que vous avez raison parfois ça n'est
pas assez concret pour l'Europe de
l'Ouest mais il faut se dire pour que ça
soit très concret que si l'Ukraine ne
gagnait pas nos frontières seraient avec
la Russie nos frontières de l'Union
européenne donc ça remet les choses en
perspective ça les tensions
sino-américaines aussi donc la question
qu'il faut se poser c'est sur ce
continent pour continuer d'assurer la
paix qui est la base de l'Union
européenne que faut-il faire et que
faut-il faire
ancré les pays du continent européen de
notre côté du côté de la démocratie du
côté de la liberté du côté des valeurs
de solidarité vous en avez beaucoup
entendu parler ici et ces valeurs là et
c'est le symbole du drapeau dont parle à
Nicolas Schmitt elles sont dans l'Union
européenne soit très clair elles ne sont
pas en Russie elles ne sont pas pour
l'instant en Chine ce n'est pas une
démocratie donc nous devons les ancrer
et pour cela nous devons travailler sur
l'élargissement et j'ai bien entendu
l'appel de Monsieur le Député l'ensemble
des États membres travaille à quel est
le meilleur moyen de sécuriser notre
continent et de procéder à
l'élargissement une unité de façade
d'ailleurs vous trouvez sur sur le sujet
des sanctions de la solidarité ou une
unité bien réelle des Européens
faisons une comparaison au moment où les
États-Unis décident d'entrer en guerre
en Irak l'Union européenne pour le coup
est divisé mais très profondément entre
deux blocs totalement antagonistes et
disons-le qui s'insulte qui s'insulte
réellement
là où est-ce qu'il y aurait la moindre
feuille de papier à cigarettes le
Premier ministre hongrois quand il est à
Budapest oui maugré il proteste etc
contre les sanctions en vérité
ils défend monsieur Poutine mais quand
il arrive à Bruxelles et qu'il faut
voter sur les sanctions contre la Russie
il les votent c'est-à-dire que en vérité
il y a uneanimité complète de l'Union
européenne sur cette question là et
c'est le début à mes yeux ce sont les
premiers pas d'une politique étrangère
commune et certainement d'une politique
de défense commune parce que
rappelons-le nous en sommes les 27
européens à acheter des munitions en
commun non seulement pour regarnir nos
stocks mais surtout pour livrer des
armes à la ukrainienne pour qu'elle
puisse se défendre mais avec
effectivement on disait une guerre
Victor negrescu des conséquences assez
dures aussi pour les Européens un IV de
vie qui était très bas en Roumanie c'est
d'un des pays les plus pauvres de
l'Union européenne qui qui est
véritablement encore endommagé il faut
communiquer avec les citoyens être
transparent sous tout ce qu'on fait et à
mon avis là il y a des choses à
améliorer pour expliquer vraiment
pourquoi on investit sans qu'on
milliards d'euros qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec ses fonds dans quelle mesure c'est
fonds sont utiles et pourquoi il faut
plus de front en fait également vous
parliez de l'adhésion de l'Ukraine de la
République de Moldavie à l'Union
européenne on a donné le statut de
candidat mais on n'a pas commencé les
négociations ils auraient dû également
avoir accès au fond de pré-accession à
l'Union européenne et ils n'ont pas
encore accès à ces fonds là parce qu'on
doit modifier le budget européen
également lorsqu'on parle des questions
liées à la défense et l'unité on a une
unité exceptionnelle qu'on espérait pas
mais il est pas complète il y a encore
des détails qui nous empêche d'avoir
vraiment une action plus forte en ce qui
concerne le soutien plus l'Ukraine mais
également la réponse donnée au régime de
Poutine parce qu'on le combat avait et
contre que ce régime de Poutine est-ce
que Poutine représente il faut être
clair sur ce point-là donc à ce titre il
faut tous il faut un plan monsieur le
député si vous me permettez parce que je
peux pas vous laisser dire cela nous
avons un plan il est en oeuvre comme
vous le savez le commissaire collègue de
Monsieur Nicolas Schmitt varelie le
commissaire hongrois qui est en charge
de l'élargissement et du et du voisinage
va remettre dans le mois qui vient une
évaluation sur toutes les mesures parce
que les Ukrainiens faut le dire sont
absolument extraordinaires non seulement
dans leur combat contre la Russie mais
dans leur combat pour pouvoir rentrer
dans l'Union européenne parce que pour
entrer dans l'Union européenne il faut
réformer un peu ces institutions il faut
s'assurer qu'il y ait pas de corruption
il faut s'assurer qu'il y ait pas
d'oligarque parce que c'est qui va aller
financer tout ça et donc là on les aide
bien sûr mais dans un mois on va savoir
tous les progrès qu'ils ont fait ce qui
va permettre au leader dès le mois de
juin de former des recommandations et de
préparer les travaux pour que à
l'automne entre le mois d'octobre et le
mois de décembre on présente
effectivement un plan pour les
différents pays et puis attention on est
en train de parler de pays qui ont des
situations très différentes parce qu'il
y a la Moldavie qui d'ailleurs va
accueillir le sommet de tous les pays
européens le premier juin mais il y a
aussi les Balkans qui attendent depuis
longtemps et pour ça nous allons nous
avons une nouvelle méthodologie pour
effectivement qu'il puisse avoir accès à
des fonds à des aides mais surtout à des
aides administratives pour gérer les
fonds pour un nouveau éviter la
corruption et que l'on doit emporter
avec nous voilà pour ce qui est de cette
union européenne aux côtés de l'Ukraine
mais qui doit se réinventer rapidement
face aux pressions géopolitiques elle
doit aussi construire un futur
plus vert et nous rejoignons publics
Sénat pour débattre maintenant de la
taxe carbone au Parlement européen à
Strasbourg c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Strasbourg pour
tenter de tout comprendre sur la fameuse
taxe carbone un instrument phare dans la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
le Parlement européen a donné son feu
vert le 18 avril dernier pour un
mécanisme inédit d'ajustement carbone
aux frontières qui s'appliquera aux
industries entreprises à partir de 2023
à titre d'essai pour une mise en œuvre
en 2026 il consiste à taxer les
émissions de CO2 des produits importés
les plus polluants ceci seront bientôt
donc soumis à un prélèvement obligatoire
s'ils ont été conçus dans des conditions
environnementales dégradées c'est-à-dire
avec un dumping environnemental la
nouveauté c'est un autre mécanisme qui
va s'appliquer au ménage européen à
partir de 2027 puisqu’une majorité
d'euros députés à voter pour l'extension
des quotas d'émissions de carbone au
transport routier et au chauffage
domestique une mesure qui fait grincer
des dents en période de forte inflation
et qui suscite des inquiétudes très bon
nombre de pays quant à son acceptabilité
par les citoyens européens alors pour
tenter d'éteindre le début d'incendie et
d'alléger la facture des ménages ce
mécanisme s'accompagne d'un fond social
pour le climat doté de 87 milliards
d'euros d'ailleurs l'Union européenne
vise à réduire ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre d'au moins 55 % en 2030
c'est son objectif et nous parlons
justement des résultats possibles grâce
à cette fameuse taxter bonne en
compagnie de Mark bottenga bonjour vous
êtes heureux député belge pour la gauche
et en face de vous Stéphane Noé pardon
Nicolas et Stéphane eurodéputé roumain
du groupe des Verts alors la taxe
carbone commençons par cette idée d'une
nouvelle taxe carbone pour les ménages
européens comment est-ce possible et
comment va-t-on les taxer pour la ménage
c'est une question qui est relative au
paquet
certificat des émissions qui
s'appliquera peut-être on sait pas
encore ça dépend d'une révision
avant l'entrée en fonction en 2029 et
qui qui va demander au ménage d'avoir de
certains standards d'émission donc avant
ça il y a le temps pour rénover pour y
aller les fonds vous avez évoqué le
fonds social mais il y a d'autres font
aussi pour le pour la rénovation des
bâtiments publics et privés comme ça on
peut être préparé à ça donc ça c'est une
mesure qui est séparée de la taxe
frontière on va démarrer par expliquer
c'est la prenons un exemple si vous le
voulez bien très concret un foyer de
quatre personnes qu'il soit foyer belge
français ou autrichien peu importe qui
sauf au gaz et qui roule à l'essence
quel impact sur leurs factures comment
on va la calculer cette taxe
en fait ce qui va se passer donc vous
savez qu'il y a au niveau européen déjà
un marché de carbone donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que il y a un quota de
droite polluées en fait que les
entreprises ont et qui sont achetés
vendus sur un marché et donc l'idée
c'est si ce prix augmente mais les
émissions vont diminuer parce que ça va
devenir plus cher de polluer en fait ce
qu'on voit c'est que entre 2009 et 2019
ça va pas trop marché les émissions sont
été réduites mais de manière très très
limitée en fait pas du tout assez pour
vraiment arriver aux objectifs
climatiques alors qu'a fait une majorité
des députés européens et de
d'institutions européennes c'est de dire
on va élargir ce système aussi
effectivement au transport et au
logement et ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que on va faire le même système
marché de carbone mais que vont faire
les entreprises par exemple les
distributeurs d'essence mais ils vont
tout simplement faire passer ce prix aux
consommateur et ça veut dire que très
concrètement à la pompe à votre facture
votre essence va devenir plus cher 10
centimes de plus 11 centimes de plus au
moins au prix actuel mais évidemment si
les prix du marché de carbone sur le
marché de carbone augmente l'impact sur
la facture pour les gens à la pompe
effectivement pour le chauffage seront
encore beaucoup plus importants donc
c'est un mécanisme qui est assez
antisocial en fait parce qu'ils font
vraiment payer les consommateurs et le
font social qui vient avec vous le
connaissez ces fonds sociaux européennes
c'est jamais assez c'est des emploistres
sur une jambe de bois il est contre
au motif que ce serait antisocial pour
les ménages en pleine période en plus
d'inflation en pleine crise énergétique
effectivement ce serait répercuté sur
les ménages en général bien comprendre
de cet argument je vous rappelle qu'il
s'appelle pas de maintenant et ça
s'appelle de il s'agit de 2029 et
deuxièmement il y a aussi parmi le verre
qui était pas convaincu que ce soit le
bon moment de faire ça d'ailleurs mes
collègues français ils
étaient pas pour
[Musique]
la Commission européenne pourra dire
STOP donc il y a des garde-fous en
France c'était toute la question de la
fameuse taxe carbone sur les carburants
2018 à l'origine du mouvement des gilets
jaunes vous redoutez cette grande
sociale que pourrait engendrer cette
taxe européenne et en plus vous dites
que cette action supplémentaire nous
n'aidera pas atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques alors pourquoi alors ce qui
est très clair c'est que en France il y
a le mouvement des gilets jaunes en
Belgique aussi quand le gouvernement a
essayé d'imposer une taxe carbone en
fait les gens sont révoltés et donc le
gouvernement du faire marche arrière
aussi et ici ce qu'on voit c'est que par
la petite porte par la porte européenne
en fait on réintroduit un mécanisme et
qui a été refusé refoulé au niveau
national pour atteindre nos objectifs
climatiques comme comme le dit votre
collègue si au moins on avait ça mais
non donc c'est une mesure antisociale
d'abord qui fait payer la transition
énergétique climatique aux gens aussi
ça le fait payer aux entreprises
justement
justement on va voir qu'est-ce que vont
faire les entreprises on sait très bien
elles vont répercuter le coût sur les
gens donc vous pensez quand même pas que
les entreprises vont dire on va renoncer
à du profit quand ils peuvent faire
payer les gens donc c'est ça ce qui est
terrible et au niveau climatique il faut
insister que les prix du carbone n'ont
pas à permis de réduire suffisamment
donc on y arrive pas c'est très clair on
n'est pas sur la bonne voie pour pour
atteindre nos objectifs climatiques ici
éteindre élargir pardon un mécanisme qui
n'a pas permis d'arriver à ça à d'autres
secteurs en disant peut-être qu'on va y
arriver ça ne va pas suffire c'est qu'il
faudrait faire si on veut être ambitieux
d'un point de vue climatique c'est
obliger les entreprises à investir
imposer des normes contraignantes et pas
leur permettre de faire un marché sur
des droites polluées alors Marc bottenga
en tant que membre de la gauche vous
êtes certainement d'accord avec cette
autre mesure concernant la taxe carbone
qui est un mécanisme à la frontière qui
en effet empêche un dumping
environnemental d'entreprise soit
délocaliser qu'il soit étrangères
comment ça marche d'abord expliquer nous
alors l'idée de ce mécanisme
d'ajustement aux frontières c'était quoi
c'était entre autres focalisé sur
l'acier l'acide uriologie pourquoi la
production d'acier vert est considérée
plus cher que la
fabrication d'acier non vert il s'agit
de 100 200 euros de plus bon
quelle est l'idée alors quand nous
produisons en Europe de l'acier vert et
si on a si c'est moins cher d'importer
de l'acier plus polluant mais du coup le
marché va préférer évidemment les
entreprises vont préférer l'acier moins
du coup faisons un mécanisme qui permet
d'ajuster ses prix ça c'est l'idée dans
cette idée on peut dire voilà il y a une
logique le problème ici à mon avis est
double ah il y a beaucoup d'autres
industries qui se disent mais alors
notre acier va devenir plus cher par
exemple le le Président Directeur
Général d'ArcelorMittal en géant de
l'acier au niveau européen a déjà dit
ben nous on va tout simplement augmenter
les prix pour nos clients leurs clients
c'est qui c'est les autres entreprise
qui risque du coup de repercuter le prix
je pense qu'il y a d'autres mécanismes
dont on a besoin pour forcer en fait les
entreprises européennes des investir
dans l'acier vert ça s'est fait au
Pays-Bas récemment il y a une énorme
mobilisation du plus grand syndicat du
syndicat aux Pays-Bas le FNV qui a dit
il y a tata style ici qui est une grande
entreprise on va les obliger à
réinvestir leur profit dans la
production de l'acier vers parce que ça
ça garantit vraiment l'emploi en Europe
donc ce mécanisme il est vous dites
qu'il est imparfait
nous t'as l'idée de cet acte monsieur
boutenguella dit c'est de verdir les
importations de l'Union européenne mais
également de
thé contre une concurrence déloyale ça
n'empêche pas pour autant les
industriels européens d'être inquiets
alors qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez
donc dans cette lutte pour arriver au
but qu'on a posé pour 2030 qui est dans
8 ans 7 ans même on peut pas aller vers
ce but sans faire des sacrifices et sans
faire vraiment des choix vous vous
appelez
des choix donc
c'est pas les industriels européens qui
vont subir les coûts les plus grands
c'est les destuels de l'extérieur de la
Chine de la Russie et là c'est une
question de d'être correcte d'être
équitable vers nos industries ici en
Europe qui doivent déjà subir des règles
qui sont plus hautes en matière
environnementale alors que en dehors de
l'Union il profite de de fait qu'ils
peuvent produire avec un grand dépense
de carbone ce qui nous affecte à la fin
donc pour moi c'est une question de
justice sociale à la fin d'imposer cet
axe à l'extérieur je veux dire la même
chose en tant que rapporteur pour le
budget 2023 je vais dire que cet axe va
aussi
être
reçu comme comme un revenu
beaucoup de sous au budget européens ce
qui veut dire que nous pouvons augmenter
nos dépenses sociales environnementales
et il y a une question aussi de d'équité
qui est démonté par l'industrie
européenne vous avez évoqué
arsenormittal bon ils sont présents ici
en Europe mais c'est pas vraiment une
société
européenne à la fin mais qui demande de
des astuces et industriels qui viennent
à l'extérieur de respecter la même règle
que nous ça devrait vous plaire ça la
différence quand même l'idée c'est que
il y a des entreprises chinoises
peut-être même américaine qui vont être
à un niveau qu'on va forcer en quelque
sorte à avoir des normes
environnementales supérieures s'ils
veulent vendre au même prix chez nous ou
alors payer ses pollueurs payeurs
pourquoi pourquoi ça vous êtes aussi
réservé il y a un fort lobby d'ailleurs
des entreprises étrangères contre ce
texte je voudrais c'est quelque chose
qui a permette vraiment de verdir
l'industrie en Europe et pour ça il faut
obliger les entreprises présentes en
Europe de réinvestir leur profit vers la
production on va peut-être pouvoir
investir également dans cette industrie
plus verte donc
je pense que la première chose c'est
quand même de dire les entreprises qui
font du profit ici doivent garantir
l'emploi en Europe et doivent verdir
leurs production je pense que ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point qui
est potentiellement problématique c'est
que c'est pas forcément parce que vous
imposez ce mécanisme que les autres
producteurs vont verdir leurs production
ils pourraient se limiter à exporter
ailleurs et du coup on aurait marché
commun européen
pour ces entreprises chinoises
américaines notons par exemple qu'avec
les sanctions contre la Russie par
exemple la Russie a réussi à envoyer
certains produits plus facilement vers
d'autres pays donc il faut qu'on fasse
attention à ce à cette chose là après
c'est vrai que les revenus qui vont être
générés pourront être utilisés mais là
on touche à un autre problème du budget
européen c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
remboursement des prêts par rapport aux
plans de relance posent énormément
question et vont demander énormément de
fonds donc combien de cet argent va
effectivement pouvoir être utilisé
libéré dans les cadres de tous les
impôts de l'Union européenne c'est pas
encore si clair donc je ne dis pas que
le mécanisme est totalement à rejeter il
est totalement mais il y a vraiment de
sérieux problèmes actuellement
les intérêts qu'on paye pour le plan
relance dans l'ordre de 400 millions
cette année et on parle de quand même
des 14 milliards donc c'est revenu
important qui est pas qu'on parle au
paiement des intérêts je pense que le
plan de relance c'est un nécessaire pour
l'Europe oui c'était quelque chose bien
prononcé actuellement il est pas financé
quand même sur le risque de
délocalisation massive parce que les
matières premières importées vont être
taxées mais les produits transformés ne
le sont pas pour l'instant dans ce
mécanisme et notamment ça pourrait
profiter à des pays très accueillants en
ce moment comme les États-Unis on le
sait bien est-ce que c'est pas un peu
contre-productif en fait le règlement
ils prévoient déjà le fait de ce qu'ils
appellent down streaming c'est-à-dire
à quel point tu vas dans la chaîne de
production et il
mention aussi un mécanisme de
vérification pour que ça se passe pas
donc il y a deux buts avec cette
législation de faire une une
de nivelley la compétition en ce qui
concerne les acteurs extérieurs mais
aussi de éviter le green washing
c'est-à-dire des gens qui produisent en
Europe et après deux localise disons un
pays aux frontières pour
pour ne pas respecter la législation
européenne et c'est empêcher les deux
cas sont empêchés vous entendez les
alertes sur les délocalisations massives
c'est le problème de toute mesure
protectionniste donc le protectionnisme
et c'est pour ça que d'un point de vue
climatique et d'un point de vue social
il faut être extrêmement
prudent quand on prend des mesures qui
vont dans le sens d'un protectionnisme
pourquoi parce que vous n'êtes pas mais
parce que on n'est pas dans un monde où
on fait ce qu'on veut sans réaction vous
savez que toute mesure que vous prenez
les autres pays vont réagir peut-être
même une guerre commerciale des guerres
commerciales qui n'aident en rien le
social ni les climats ou alors on va
inspirer d'autres pays on va aspirer
d'autres pays mais à faire quoi parce
que par exemple moi ce que je pense
c'est que a comme je disais garantir
l'emploi ici garantir le
réinvestissement des profits fait en
Europe c'est une chose une deuxième
chose si on veut vraiment aider le
climat permettons au pays qui sont en
cours d'industrialisation d'utiliser les
meilleures techniques donc d'utiliser
les meilleures technologies qui
aujourd'hui existent
partageant par exemple cette technologie
avec ces pays-là et là on serait
effectivement sur un level playing field
donc un nivellement on touche chacun
pour une concurrence non faussée où
chacun a en faveur du climat les
meilleurs technologies à disposition et
là effectivement on va faire avancer
tout le monde plutôt que d'arriver dans
une guerre commerciale où ce sera au
moins 10 ans merci à vous d'avoir très
bien illustré ce débat sur les taxes
carbone il y en a plusieurs on l'a bien
compris et vous restez sur nos antennes
pour la suite des programmes
[Musique]